okay so the final topic in this add-on
section is generalized linear models so
we've seen that linear regression is
used for a quantitative response
logistic regression is the counterpart
for a binary response and models the
logit of the probability as a linear
model
so these are two response types but
others exist such as non-negative
responses skewed distributions and more
so generalized linear models provide a
unified framework for dealing with many
different response types
and so that's what we're going to talk
about here we're going to go through a
simple example which is going to
illustrate an important member of this
family which uses poisson regression and
for that we're going to use
the bike share data which is a data set
that measures some variables for bike
rental company in washington dc
so in this case the response is bikers
which is the number of hourly users in
the bike share program in washington dc
you've got a bunch of variables you've
got the temperature whether or not it's
a working day
the weather situation with this cloudy
misty light rain snow
there's a base level for weather which
is clear
and then two other variables with lots
of levels which we haven't put in this
kind of a nova plot
which is the month of the year
and we actually plot in their
coefficients just as a function of month
and the hour of the day is 24 hours of
the day and so we plot each hour as a
point here
but ideally these all belong in this
table
we just for the linear regression model
we show the coefficients the standard
just the usual stuff it looks like
everything's significant it's a quite a
large data set
and we can see from the month
figure that
there's more bicycles rented in may and
june then during the hot months in dc
there's fewer
than in the fall more again and of
course in the winter very few
and then hour of the day there's a
natural kind of partition as well
more rented at the beginning of the
workday at the end of the work day
because people use it as a means of
public transport
and then different amounts during the
day there's a lunch time period as well
so that's fine but the response is the
number of hourly users okay
so the number of value users first of
all it's a non-negative variable
and
here we've shown
a picture just of of
the the response file versus hour of the
day
and we put a smoothing spline foot
through this just so that you can see as
just for the single variable what the
mean looks like
as a function of hour of the day
and what you see is that when the mean
is low
the spread is is somewhat low but when
the mean is higher the spread seems to
get bigger
right
so the for the most part the variance
seems to increase with the mean now when
we fit linear regression models we we're
really assuming that the variance
of y is constant
okay this is just showing one variable
but if you put the full linear model
like we did before
ten percent of the linear model
predictions are negative
because there's no constraints on the
linear model that the predictions should
be positive even though the response is
always positive
in the cases like this you might be
tempted to rather model the log of the
bikers
the counts of bikers but it has its own
problems example predictions on the
wrong scale because you really want to
make predictions on the bikes number of
biker scale not on the log scale
and some of the counts could be zero and
so you can't take logs
so that's not in general a good solution
here's a picture of of the log of the
bikers
and with the same as a similar smooth
curve put through
it seems like the variance is is more
stable on the log scale as a function of
the mean
but there's some weird stuff going on
down here when you're taking logs of of
small counts
and for the zeros
well these are logs of those arrows so
these must be the ones but any zero
counts
were either left out or some pharjin had
to be done
so this is where the poisson model comes
in so just like we use the binomial
model for zero one data turns out the
poisson regression or the poisson
distribution is good for modeling counts
so
for those who are interested this is the
form for the poisson probability mass
function
so it gives an explicit form for the
probability that y equals k
and it's controlled by parameter lambda
which is the mean count
in the distribution
and for the poisson it turns out that
the variance
is equal to the mean
so when the means higher the variance is
higher so that's a property of the
poisson distribution by the way for the
binomial distribution
the variance also depends on the mean
if for a binomial distribution if the
mean is p
then the variance is p times 1 minus p
for the bernoulli distribution and that
tends to be a property of this class of
glms that we're talking about
except for the gaussian
okay so this is just for a single
poisson distribution but we're
interested in a poisson distribution
where the mean
changes with the coverts so now instead
of just writing lambda we're going to
write lambda as a function of x
and what we're going to do is we're
going to assume that the log of lambda
is a linear function of x
so just like for the logistic regression
we assume the logit of the probability
was a function of x
here we're assuming the log of the mean
is a function of x
or you can invert that transformation
and says that lambda is e to the linear
combination of the coordinates of x
so you can see that automatically
guarantees that the mean is positive
in this case
we can fit
this model and we fit it by maximum
likelihood we're not going to go into
the details but we use the poisson as
the basis for the fit in
and we can fit that model and get a
summary
and just like we did for logistic
regression and for linear regression you
get a summary that identifies the
coefficients for each variable and gets
standard errors
and p-values and so on and so this is
very similar you'll see these
coefficients are different because these
are on the log scale
than for the linear model
but they're going to have the similar
message
but the nice thing is that when you fit
this poisson model it takes this change
in variance into account when it does a
fit in
and again we just show us dot plots
the effects estimated for month and for
hour
and if you if you compare back you'll
see that is somewhat similar
it turns out in this case the variance
is actually somewhat larger than the
mean for the plus and we're assuming the
variance is the same as the mean and but
this is a well-known situation when you
fit poisson data and it's known as
overdispersion
so the p-values are misleadingly small
in this in this plot
in this table here and but you can get
corrected p-values by accommodating this
over dispersion but we don't go into
that here
so we've covered three generalized
linear models in this course gaussian
binomial and now poisson so they each
have a characteristic link function
this is the transformation of the mean
that is represented by a linear model
and we write it like this eta as the
link function of the mean
and it's the transformation of the mean
that's a linear model
so the link functions for linear
logistic and poisson regression
are for the linear model it's just the
identity link
it just uses to say the model amine
directly
for logistic regression it's a logic
link
because in logistic regression the mean
for the binomial is the probability
and for poisson it's a log link
and how do you decide which which of
these models to use
well it's
um it's the nature of the response room
so for person the the response are these
counts and so we decide that we need a
distribution that's suitable for counts
for binary data
it's you know bernoulli is pretty much
any distribution because if it's a
quantitative variable we'll just use
gaussian if it if it looks like
um you know if it's got a nice symmetric
distribution
turns out they also have characteristic
variance functions and we talked about
that the variance for the poisson is
equal to the mean
then the models are fit by maximum
likelihood and summaries like the ones
we showed are produced by the glm
function in r
and the other glms that we haven't
talked about include the gamma
distribution
a negative binomial which is which
despite the name is actually used in the
case of counts but when you've got extra
over dispersion there's also the inverse
gaussian distribution
the gamma distribution is often used
when you've got positive observations
or non-negative observation and you've
got long tails to the right
the gamma's is often used
and there's more so you know so this the
glms are quite a big family we've just
told you about the more important ones